are you disappointed with the lack of  snow this winter city skylines has you  covered publisher paradox interactive  has revealed the new snowfall expansion  snowfall brings a new winter map later  this year which will challenge you with  keeping your buildings well heated and  keeping your roads clear you'll also get  new vehicles like trams and of course  snowplows anyone playing city skylines  will also receive a free update that  adds rain and fog we don't know exactly  when the expansion is releasing and we  don't know the final price the first  expansion after dark ran for fifteen  dollars so a similar amount makes sense  gamespot gave that expansion an 8 out of  10 so it's safe to say we're excited for  more content and for all the news about  city skylines you're already in the  right place